face it your house is filthy it's filled
with dead skin cells dust and around
200,000 different species of bug
bacteria and fungus now it's tempting to
assume that most of them live in your
toilet after all it's where you know but
here's the thing the dirtiest place in
your house isn't your toilet it's
actually you household microbes lurk in
the most unlikely of places
take a heat-loving bacteria called
thermus aquaticus these guys can only be
found in two environments blisteringly
hot geysers like Old Faithful at
Yellowstone and your hot water heater
another example is Penicillium fungi
they creep into your air conditioner
from outdoors when you switch on the AC
their spores it blasts around the house
and are known to cause allergies in 2 to
6% of people so when you notice a funny
musty smell coming from your AC it's
probably the fungus but before you start
on your central air suspiciously think
about this you dump microbes all over
your body every time you shower it turns
out trillions of organisms live in your
shower head piled on top of each other
in a slimy layer half a millimeter thick
but that's not necessarily a problem
researchers found that a type of shower
dwelling micro bacterium actually boosts
levels of serotonin
that's a neurotransmitter thought to
lower stress and increase happiness and
when those errant mycobacterial land on
you they join the tens of thousands of
other microbe species that live in the
dirtiest place around your body like
chlorine a bacteria the microbes that
give your armpits that stinky odor and
simultaneously fight off harmful
pathogens like e.coli meanwhile 300 to
500 species of microbe colonize your gut
and are thought to play a role in
maintaining your immune system digestive
system and even mental health in the non
bacterial category of microbes you've
got such guests as microscopic mites
live on your face and mold that
colonizes your toes and while the idea
of them might give you chills microbes
like these help keep you safe you see
the number of harmless microbial species
in the world outnumber harmful ones by a
trillion to one in fact less than point
zero zero zero zero zero zero zero one
percent of microbial species account for
nearly all infectious diseases in the
world and all these harmless bacteria
crawling on your skin means less room
and resources for pathogens like
antibiotic resistant microbes which also
means they have less opportunity to take
over and make you sick so even when
antibiotics fail it could be all those
other microbes crawling in and on you
that keep you safe so in a way you need
to get a little dirty to stay healthy
but full disclosure that's not an excuse
to swear off your shower besides you
don't want to miss out on that feel-good
micro bacterium this video was made in
large part thanks to Rob Dunn and the
information in his new book never home
alone